[Music]
welcome to swipe from the gfinity East
Sports Arena in London here's what we've
got the on this week's program I'm going
behind the scenes at the UK's only
dedicated eSports Arena and thing is
we're in the perfect place for
discussing video games we invited this
week swipe games reviewer Simon Miller
down what's on your list for us well
this week I've got the latest Batman
game from telltale got the long dark
I've got Patapon remastered and I've got
a Mega Man Legacy Collection to that and
then we'll be going from London to Paris
where angela has been visiting the
world's biggest startup campus it will
be coming the next ten minutes but first
let's take a look at some of this week's
tech news headlines Google and Facebook
could face fines stretching into
billions of pounds if they breach users
privacy under a new law the vines are
part of the data protection bill which
the government is introducing to give
citizens more control over their data
Facebook is launching a new platform in
the US which could rival the likes of
YouTube and TV networks it'll appear as
a watch tab in users fees the man who
first told us to use capital letters
numbers and symbols in our passwords
says he regrets much of his guidance
from 14 years ago the combinations often
led to users having to write down their
tricky to remember passwords weakening
security bill burr who worked for the US
government at the time has told the Wall
Street Journal in hindsight it was
barking up the wrong tree there are
plans to roll out eSports Training clubs
for young people this after a successful
pilot scheme with Westminster Council
which laid on a free after-school Club
in London for a month with sessions
focusing on gameplay and future careers
in eSports and we also heard this week
that the Paris Olympic bid team wants to
explore making esports and medal events
at the 2024 games
so this is an eSports arena and if you
haven't been keeping across the surge
and high level competitive video gaming
in recent years here's a man who can
help explain more martin Wyatt from
gfinity the eSports company Martin this
must be your office for two days of the
week yeah absolutely we're we're very
lucky to be able to call this home and
during a weekend during during the
season it's packed with screaming fans
who are you know just going mental to
see there the players of their fans of
and some of the world's best gamers
there's very much is the equivalent of
Wembley Stadium how does a player get to
compete here it's exactly the same as
any sports man sports women sort of
reaching the top of their field it's
about dedication and practice is there a
lot of cash involved there's plenty of
money involved yeah you know it starts
sort of quite low but you know there are
major salaries there are sort of six
seven figure salaries now being earned
by some players around the world yeah
I'd love to go for a little look round
would you show us behind the seat
absolutely come come with me
[Music]
yes we're now backstage from underneath
the main stage where all the actions
currently taking place up top and this
is actually one of the most important
rooms that actually we're gonna get to
see too often this is our warm-up area
so this is where we bring the players
before they're ready to compete to get
game ready getting the zone exactly this
is kind of a holding area for people go
into makeup and into the greenroom some
of the talent going to the greenroom a
lot of energy drinks yeah yeah a lot of
energy drinks no these guys play hard
they they put of effort into it so we
kind of keep them topped up so how many
hours would they typically be playing
for well it depends what it depends on
the game you know the tournaments will
run anywhere between four to ten hours
depending on the games that they're
playing this is a very very important
room this is our league Operations
Officer a little quick squeeze inside
see if the guys are busy working away
hey guys so these are these are two of
our League Ops guys these are the guys
that designed the tournaments they make
sure they're running according to
schedule according to plan and yeah
they're kind of the referees as well so
they make sure no one messes around to
today's technology exactly yeah
something some way saving for me
so now upstairs we're behind the
mainstage this is where it's all getting
very very serious the last-minute nerves
are kicking in yeah people are talking
about the last-minute tactics but from
here they go to walk the tunnel and then
it's out in front of the part of the
adoring fans yeah this is like the
celebrity moment for them
yeah very much so very much so yeah this
is the famous gfinity tunnel the point
of no return if someone's like to call
it and yeah they're walking down here
they're getting ready they're out in
front of the adoring fans or going mad
and you know it's really really close
now a couple of minutes before they're
they're kind of ready to play how would
you summarize how big eSports has become
in the UK it's the eSports industry as a
whole is massive you know I think that a
couple years ago people to viewing it
viewed it as a nation now very very big
niche but you know it's knocking on the
door of mainstream in the UK it's fair
to say we're very much behind the likes
of South Korea North America parts of
parts of Europe but you know the UK very
much is a sleeping giant in the world of
eSports and that's what the whole the
whole idea behind u infinity is a
business and the gfinity elite series is
to wake that giant up and make the UK
effectively they're the go-to place in
the world for eSports and if you fancy
yourself as an eSports champion one day
there are plenty of titles out there to
get practising on Simon's ready to give
us his review of some of the latest
video game releases the Mega Man Legacy
Collection 2 is the follow-up to last
year's the Mega Man Legacy Collection
lis this time you get Mega Man 7 mega
man 8 Mega Man 9 and Mega Man 10 now
these aren't remasters and Capcom has
literally taken the old games and just
made sure you can play them on your ps4
your Xbox one of your PC but now they're
a lot easier because as you'll know if
you ever played Mega Man before those
games are well too hard now you've got
save points you've got checkpoints and
if you really want to take the
difficulty down you can even add armor
to Mega Man and then enemies don't do as
much damage now this is the ultimate
nostalgia trip for any Mega Man fan I
highly advise you get it if you're into
the franchise
Patapon remastered for the ps4 is an
updated version of Patapon that came out
for the PSP around about 10 years ago
now this is one of the strangest games
you're ever likely to play is half
real-time strategy and it's half rhythm
actions and that means you don't just
push left you know just push right you
hear the time and the beat of the music
and you hit the corresponding face
button to make your Patapon attack your
enemy or to just progress through the
level now at times this does get really
complicated when I say really
complicated I mean really complicated
not a patient person I would advise you
don't play this however if you like
quirky games you like weird games and
you like games that make you think
Patapon remastered it most definitely
for you but again it's really really
strange
the long dark is the latest survival
game to come to the ps4 and Xbox one and
to sum up as quickly as I can it is
incredibly hard now this is a survival
game meaning your objective is to
survive but you do that by having to
worry about every little thing therefore
if you're hungry you got to find food to
eat and if you're thirsty you got to
find something to drink and if you're
cold you've got to start a fire now the
long dark treats this as if you're a
real human being and therefore if you
don't do any of these things in time
you're gonna die you know again then you
die again and when you think you've got
the hang of it you realize there's
something else to learn and you die
again so in short this is a very
difficult game however you like things
are addictive and you like games they're
going to take you weeks to finish you
should look into this but again it's not
easy you're going to get very frustrated
so don't say I didn't warn you
Batman Season 2 episode 1 the enemy
within is Telltale's follow-up to the
original they released last year and I'm
pleased to say that so far this is
shaping up to be far better than that
one ever was following the story of both
Bruce Wayne and Batman you're introduced
to the Riddler there's a bunch of other
news faces too and also there's the
overwhelming sense that the Joker is
about to arrive on the scene
now to give away too much here would be
unfair because you really want to go out
there and experience it for yourself
however telltale has done a great job
here and if it all goes how it should
this is gonna be one of those games that
you tell your friends about especially
throw a DC Comics friend gonna be like
go play the new Batman game it's really
good the fingers crossed we're gonna
change the scenery completely now and
head across the channel to catch up with
Angela she's been in Paris at a new
startup campus said to be the biggest in
the world iconic sites like this of what
Paris is most famous for now a 34,000
square metre space the size of the
Eiffel Tower is also hoping to make a
mark Station F is home to 1,000 tech
startups from around the world it's
hoped this new campus will transform the
tech sector in France and even take
advantage of post brexit uncertainty
rocks and vazha a former major player in
Silicon Valley is tasked with running it
a lot of political factors playing into
the current climate that we have here in
France so we actually have startups that
have applied here that have said things
like brexit Donald Trump high silicon
valley prices have actually played into
why they look at coming to station F and
why they want to come to friend startups
from several different industries and
venture capital funds are all under one
roof those behind station F hope that by
bringing them together it will create
global companies other big companies are
also running their own startup
accelerators here Facebook and Microsoft
are just a couple of the big names and
they're running weekly
workshops for these new companies to
learn from them and in turn they're
collaborating it's helping them to
innovate to recast AI is one of the
companies selected to work with
Microsoft to help innovate in artificial
intelligence 330i we are developing
technology that allows machines to
understand natural language human
language and technology is available
through a platform a collaborative
platform for developers and companies to
help them build chat BOTS that's just
one of the programs at station of the
project has the support of the country's
new president Manuel macron who attended
the opening he's pledged 10 billion
euros to help turn France into a startup
nation and vowed to change laws to
assist job creation in the sector in the
UK some experts say London is ready for
the competition and post brexit
challenges the critical thing is being
staying open to that talent from across
Europe and around the world
so that message has got to be sent loud
and clear by government and by business
and that's really what London's got to
focus on station F is the latest project
to try and lure tech talent across the
channel with a global talent pool is
still divided Angela Barnes Sky News in
Paris France well that's it for this
week don't forget join us again for more
swag next week and why don't follow us
on Twitter last time you swipe see you
guys soon bye bye
you
[Music]